[Musique]
ce que vous voyez dans le bâtiment jaune ici
est l'endroit où
le fondateur du bâton de menthe poivrée à
Grenade, Amalia Exxon, a vécu
pendant près de 50 ans.
Nous avons cette photo de cette dame à l'
âge de 80 ou 90 ans,
elle est née en 1824.  ici à Grana et
est mort à l'âge de 99 ans
[Musique]
et le portugais est tordu rouge et
blanc tordu comme la danse qui tourne en
rond c'est pourquoi le nom
polka de la danse en Grèce
ou cochon
pour les petits bonbons en Suède
la ville  tout tourne autour du steak à la menthe poivrée
ou de la polka grecque, il y a 10
12 usines le long de cette route principale, le ballon
s'est remis à
produire des bâtonnets de menthe poivrée
ou des poltergeists des bulgaris des
portugais,
donc c'est
une gamme de saveurs comme vous le voyez, nous en avons
beaucoup  différentes saveurs
mais celle-ci
est rouge et une rayure blanche
et
avec une saveur de menthe poivrée, c'est l'
original
qu'Amalia a inventé en 1859
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
ici, nous avons du sucre, beaucoup de sucre, un peu
d'eau
et du vinaigre vraiment très fort
et  ça bout à
145 degrés Celsius environ
et puis on verse la pâte sur cette table
[Musique]